hands down my favorite episode it blew
my mind
in so many different ways so first you
initially get pitched
love craft country but at what point do
you find out what you're actually gonna
have to go through in episode five
so i get told about the
race switching on my second audition
which is kind of a zoom audition and i'm
like
sorry what how are we gonna do that
um and the actor in me is like uh
am i basically gone after episode five
and so
but then you know it was
really it was such a shock and like just
the politics of it like
oh but why why did she do that why would
you do
of course of course it makes sense
in one respect but it
it feels like a total betrayal
of everything that i am everything that
my people are
i'm like i don't get it i don't get it
and then i have to get to a point where
i
got it and that was really painful that
was really
really painful to kind of explore those
feelings and questions and
yeah so then it was that it was that
audition when i realized it was a book
so i read the book after
and was like wow this is this is
this is pretty deep this is it's it's
painful
it's a painful choice that she makes
and it was painful for me it was painful
for jamie newman
it was painful like that that specific
scene at the end
we were both like
shaking like because we haven't ex
you know i haven't i haven't personally
but explored that rage
within within myself
never done that before never done that
never imagine like you know having to
find that is
dark i i can't even imagine from your
perspective
because i was completely overwhelmed
i think in the ways intended by this
episode
yeah i don't i don't know where to go
next maybe let's start with
the practical effects here can you kind
of walk us through
what it takes on set to shed
that skin and make that look right
cold um yeah i
i you they put all you know they kind of
start with blood and you know
paintbrush and and then they put like
gunk all over you and it's literally and
they have to do they have to do it fast
enough
because the blood is really sticky so
like
it starts to dry up and then it's like
a constant like reapplying and if you
touch someone like it it comes off
and you know and then you're kind of
like you know
you have to be semi-nude
and covering up means reapplying
so it's just kind of like there was a
lot of
um uh towel
curtains made around me and just people
just did them
just hey guys
like while they yeah i mean it's not
pleasant
oh all the unpleasantness pays off
because that
i'm just like endlessly fascinated by
practical like gore type effects and
i think that's that's some of the best
stuff that i've seen in a while
oh yeah i mean i guess it was real
though as well like
you know all the stuff in your hair and
yeah it's real like it's all there like
this it wasn't
the special effects really come in the
transition but the after
is all there like it's already
happened so with
with the effects required and also
just you know the the more personal
i guess trying to make uh make the
characters still feel true to ruby no
matter who is playing her
what is it like collaborating with jamie
in order to make that seamless
it was just it was just great like we
just talked about her
we spent a lot of time together we hung
out a lot and
i would record ruby i would record
when she was when it was a private
moment i would record her lines and it
when she was
performing i mean when she was talking
to someone else being hillary
she would you know do her thing too but
we would record our lines together and
like we just spent a lot of time
together and
and yeah all this all the thoughts about
her and letty and the things that came
into
came to me i just shared with with them
jamie we just
figured it out together a plus
collaboration right there
yeah before i leave episode five one
more question because
at the very beginning of the show ruby
is obviously very well aware
of the racism in the country but do you
think that
even even she didn't know how bad the
situation
really was before going through this
experience like how
exactly is her headspace different at
the end and do you think she kind of
like got the job done
or is that is that a rage that's going
to stick with her
i definitely think it sticks with her
i mean she's she still is a black woman
from the south side of chicago living in
a very very
in a world that's not welcoming the
world that's not built for
for her um
she
you know she the rages i just
how can the rage ever sees
i mean it's still i feel rage
and this is 2020.
and i feel
yeah i i feel a connection
to her and
so much time has passed and not enough
has changed
um yeah what is that
answers then no that that does
and it it very well captures why
i am so grateful to have shows like this
that
deal with those kinds of topics because
i feel like you know
especially from a different perspective
entertainment like that makes you feel
and understand things you might not have
been able to otherwise and if that's one
of the ways that i can access that
i'm glad a show like love craft country
exists because
i think we all need it yeah and misha
doesn't
pull
of all the the highs and lows of
the emotions that our characters go
through
um as women as black women as men as
black men
as white women you know like there's
the patriarchy you know there's so much
that she has explored the depths of
and the heights of and
yeah and it's so unbelievably
necessary to because
i feel like she's done it in a way that
hasn't got the
the you know the censorship she hasn't
censored herself i censored myself all
the time
i've i've realized i am very rarely
honest
outside of my family i'm very
very rarely honest when i step outside
of the door i
feel like i present the way i need to be
i need to present in order to
survive and feel like i can
navigate but it's it's a an energy that
i put into
it's an energy i put into navigating the
world that i'm not putting into myself
i'm not putting into my artistry i'm not
putting into my family my friends
what my dreams and hopes i'm spending
this energy
paying attention figuring out how to
to be in this world
that doesn't feel like it's for me and
misha has taken this to
oh she has just said no this is it like
we're not pulling any punches we're not
we're not gonna be
we're not gonna ask for forgiveness
we're not gonna we're just gonna
i'm just gonna say it how i see it say
how i feel it